hi everyone and welcome to house of
horrors I'm serene I'm Jess and today
we're playing paranormal which is
described itself as a fully dynamic
haunting experience that sounds
terrifying
yes so the the stick of this game is
basically each time you play it's
something different that happens it's
not the same thing that's going at the
same thing twice this game was released
as a mod originally I think you came out
lost
not lost you start with 2012 yeah and it
is now on Steam greenlight and also
available on Dussehra and it's developed
by matt Cohen I have come to believe
that my house is haunted by these people
in here and I've started recording
things to try and prove diffuse so
someone described this to me Paranormal
Activity the game it takes that makes me
uncomfortable psychology as movies if
the game gets too scary hide they'll
find you anyway though you guys don't
remember from two weeks ago
serene actually really doesn't like
mannequins 1980 oh haha kill the baby I
don't hear the pain my hell was going on
in here I don't know man haven't you
been living here in your belly yes I
covered this noobs I was so short I
don't really see me crouching no we're
so short
Cheska oh is that a phone
oh okay okay
the sink is clogged quick cold the
pumice it by my bed when I'm sleeping
tonight
okay all right let's go upstairs yeah
d-die it's gonna say diving or diving
board dinner okay this is the stationary
cameras yeah yeah yeah was I supposed to
pick up the phones and what kind of
wallpaper is that we're eating my
daddy's it sounded like a grenade going
off nice vegetation that's very nice
whoa there's not a nice photo to have in
the bathroom to eat dark corners man
well someone pushed me over hey that's
not very nice stop stop what yes hi
would you describe holding great I get
the feeling that it wants me dead and
gone to be honest with you thank God
that we G board that I said if it's a
strong to use a Ouija board if you do
you're letting this entity know that
you're willing to communicate damn it
then how the hell else do I get rid of
it going to give you the number of
colleague of mine he's a demonologist
we've been friends for many years
no dr. Powell
no hey whoa oh what's that injury [ __ ]
man out this is a worst ad for this
camera this camera lost like ten minutes
let's sleep and weekend there train can
go out of here
was that your dream I hate when that
happens to me yeah yeah oh yeah a I want
to hang out with me I looked at pulling
the chair out for me - isn't that oh
that's sweet oh yeah I kind of get a
saying Jessa's good she's gone Russian
dude - everything's fine everything's
fine Oh
Megan's in the doorway oh it seems to be
moving but that's fine I swear it was oh
jeez odd noises what are you - mannequin
what was that what was that so we call
the shadows music cat cat I'm getting
out of here
see yep cat c-130 it's been six minutes
oh my god I'm sorry I'm getting out of
your way oh my gosh Oh what the hell me
Darby says he's scared makes me skin I
hate it when the protagonist
was that he before I know I have a lot
of nerve for this I have a lot of nerve
I don't want to be in the Attic we're in
the attic basement
oh no stake I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
should we get out yeah yellow Sanchez
sing unlock the safe and the wall yeah I
see it it's a mannequin I think friends
you gonna eat our face I can't get
through you know Larry on Twitter saying
that wait here serious oh yeah yeah
how do I win this game what's wrong did
we die what's happening yeah I guess we
died David is saying we were mannequins
announcing you know because it was so
small back to square one
yeah it's later in the night yeah it is
this time 143 maybe Carrie's Bosch's
needle tiny fish swimming in that query
what do you think I should do do you
want to make you do you want me to do
is moving it's moving moving moving
everything's moving oh not really sure
how to approach this sorry didn't mean
to interrupt your satanic ritual laughs
little mannequin buddies giggle oh this
uh yep that one looks like a groobly
this is a really fun game okay it's just
a good ab workout but I got that going
for me
stick it in crazy kids yeah I was saying
now is not the time to be reading
casually something weeds happened uh I
think we established that a while ago
he's felt like doing a bit of sleep odd
sleep
no no no no oh we haven't seen a person
in this game no just just just in like
nope no everyone is so dope right now
Yuli something tells me I shouldn't go
there
damn you Marcus dead dead either way
oh that was paranormal the game was this
cool paranormal on Steam greenlight and
Asura um if you wanted to check that one
out yeah as usual let us know what you
thought about the game in the comments
both on YouTube and GameSpot and on
Twitter with the hey chohee july of
hashtag and we're more than happy to
take your suggestions as well and if
you're an indie game developer and you'd
like us to check your game out feel free
to ping either Jess or myself and we'll
see what we can do yeah see you same
time next week everyone bye